question one what's the missing number
in this pattern you can see if you
follow all of these numbers on the left
hand side these guys here they are
always decreasing by three as you move
from left to right so if you decrease by
three one more time that's what gives
you negative three when you had a look
at this next part it said write a
mathematical sentence so you can see
when Brad bought six packets of tennis
balls and each packet had five boys in
it that's where six times five comes
from following that he lost seven of
them so that's why there is subtraction
by seven in the sentence okay following
along and I know there are some
questions about this one
question three that is part a I think
everyone recognized 16 is clearly bigger
than for Part B that fraction sign is
just another way to say division but
what's of you have questions about Part
C now let me explain the real issue is
confusion about what that symbol means
let me read that for you just in case
you can't remember because to be fair
it's been awhile since we looked at this
that statement means 9 times 7 is
greater than or equal to 7 times 9 now
that is why a lot either are 9 times 7
is 63 7 times 9 according to the
commutator of law is also 63 right so 9
times 10 is not bigger than 7 times 9
but it is greater than or equal to and
that's what that little line down there
which is just like an equal sign is 4 ok
I know there were lots of questions that
okay so I think that's what it answers
most of the questions that people have
on those it's a little bit of notation
now you know it so relax okay
I'm gonna skip along to four you can see
hamish did the long division in the
answer column and the bold and italic
numbers are the ones that have been
filled in so you can see the four at the
top is already there so what do you do
with that for you multiply it by 19
that's what gives you the 76 that
belongs there and then you continue
through and you can see where the rest
of this goes from 91 takeaway 76 that
gives you the 15 and then you bring down
that too that's already told to you but
then you write this last number 8
because perfect and that was it okay so
let's turn up the page this picture
shows a section of a party decoration so
what's going on there were too much here
and a lot of you will find this a tick
and a cross maybe because you
demonstrated something you had some of
this kind of working somewhere but maybe
you didn't quite get the final answer
which is 968 so you can see there and
this is just to give you a general
guideline the first mark is for
recognizing that you had to do a
division and you had to divide by 2 and
that's because of how many of the
decorations you can fit it has 2 stars
for every tier in there two stars for
every 11 centimeters and then it says
one mark for multiplying 88 by 11
because that's how many gaps you're
going to get okay so two bucks there
number six without dividing through how
can we tell so do you remember this is
about the divisibility tests we have
divisibility test for 2 3 4 5 6 etc so
the idea is to say what you're looking
for the last two digits being divisible
that's the divisibility test for 4
similar it's our without performing a
long or short division what's the answer
we're a hundred 37 is divided by 17
if this is what happens when 136 is
divided by 17 so you could have given
your answer in either of these forms you
could have given it as I kind of would
have naturally have gone to this one
because I got exactly eight when I
divide 136 if I add one more on I get a
remainder of one but you could have
written as a fraction and that was
accepted as well okay by the way if you
didn't notice this test features our
class quite a lot Charlie made some
chocolate chip cookies he used the 20
grand
chocolate chips rather for every 100
grams how many chocolate chips did he
use okay can you see the way the working
is seven times 24 times seven hundred
and sixty grams do you follow the
working with it yeah if you didn't get
that working down maybe you had a guess
I'd like you to drop that that line of
working down in your book because that
sort of guide you as to how to do it
number nine the biggest issue here was
that people didn't quite recognize
there's more than one possible number
that Frank could be thinking of a lot of
people got 30 yes that's possible but
there are other numbers which fit all of
the rules that were just mentioned a
little bit like that problem-solving
activity we did this morning right
sometimes there's more than one answer
that fits all of the conditions okay
number 10 you just needed your
protractor to make this measurement here
number 11 the complement so that's the
difference between your angle and 90
degrees so you can see the subtraction
there and let's turn over the page
mark collides in a teller to shut their
parallel so we were looking for these
arrows here you didn't need f3 if you
just had two of them that was fine you
could put them there or you could put
the bed there okay Mabon ain't going
question 12 that's adjacent to em p.m.
so here is M p.m. right here that's this
angle so that's why you had some twice's
as to which one you wanted to say was
adjacent to that which angle is
supplementary you can read those
yourself question 15 the pair of Co
interior angles you could have said this
and this or you could have said this and
this do you see what we mean by Co area
there in between they're boxed in by
those parallel lines question 17 the
best people with their answers here they
drew a clock and they said okay at 4:00
p.m. the minute hand will be at 12th and
the our head will be well let's see here
you'd have 12 here 1 2 3 so 4 is going
to be over there pointing downwards okay
and from that you could kind of measure
out Oh yep 120 degrees because each one
of those I go 30 degrees every time and
that was a tricky question number 18 are
these angles equal yes and we were
looking for this reason here now for
both this question and some of the later
ones when we're looking for reasoning we
were try to say do you know what the
relationships between these angles on
intersecting lines or parallel lines do
you know what the words the language are
so vertically opposite was what we were
looking for there's a simple missing
there but how do we know they're
parallel you could have used either of
these reasons you could set
corresponding angles or alternate okay
let's turn over again
I'm going to skip over 20 because I
think it was quite well done or you may
have worked it out your conversations
let's have a look at 21 because his
Western problems came up find the value
so firstly alpha equals 42 but the we're
trying to focus on the reason right so
again we're looking mainly for alternate
angles the rest of it was really helpful
but the main thing we're looking for is
alternate angles and then secondly for
Part B a goes on a straight line add to
180 it's not enough to say they're
supplementary even though they are I
want to go why they're supplementary
that's why it says reason okay so
provide the reasoning and that's the
really important part